[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un métier
dont l'avons contact avec le public et
là c'est un camouflet que cette
profession je suis désolé de le dire ou
une partie de cette profession
puisqu'ils ne sont pas tous en grève une
partie de cette profession adresse au
voyageur la CFDT de la soutien pas tout
simplement parce que il y a pas dans
dans cette période un contexte
particulier qui ferait que sa justifie
de pointer ce week-end de Noël dont on
sait qu'il a un week-end ou ça circule
beaucoup surtout moi je pense aux
Français aux familles qui sont parfois
déchirés par cette grève vous la
condamné mais
au tribunal mais oui je pense que cette
grève n'est pas justifiée et celle grève
ne peut pas être comprise par les
Français Clément bonne le ministre des
Transports très occupé avec la les
grèves à une petite déconvenue il doit
aller à Arles mais comme des centaines
de milliers de Français et bien son
train a été annulé ça ne s'invente pas
lui-même Clément beau n'a rien vu venir
comme dans la crise des gilets jaunes
parce qu'on ne peut plus rien peut-être
voir venir aujourd'hui avec ce type de
phénomène 300 1500 personnes sur
Facebook la France est par terre et les
gens vont pas ouvrir leur famille ces
deux femmes qui nettoient des vitres
dans une ville du nord-est de la Chine
ont été vu des millions de fois sur les
réseaux sociaux la vidéo diffusée par un
voisin les montres en équilibre sur le
rebord des fenêtres au 11e étage d'un
immeuble sans harnais de sécurité
l'histoire retiendra bien sûr ses images
fortes
volodimeers qui remettant à la
présidence de la Chambre des
Représentants l'étendard jaune et bleu
au coeur des échanges les livraisons
d'armes toujours plus demande une
journaliste au président américain
la réponse est oui
je suis d'accord répond le président
ukrainien le chef d'État est reparti
dans son pays et la réaction de la
Russie ne s'est pas fait attendre nous
pouvons constater avec regret que ni le
président Biden ni le président Zelenski
non dit quoi que ce soit qui puisse être
perçu comme une volonté potentielle
d'écouter les préoccupations de la
Russie
mènent deux facto une guerre indirecte
contre Moscou très prisé pour les
cadeaux à glisser sous le sapin le
Scrabble fait évoluer sa liste de mots
et décide d'en interdire près de 400 des
mots jugés offensants certains à
caractère raciste ou homophobe mais pas
uniquement mais en pratique comment
faire pour que les joueurs ne les
utilisent plus le tueur en série
français Charles sauvage incarcéré au
Népal va être libéré emprisonné depuis
2003 pour le meurtre de deux touristes
nord-américains la Cour suprême a estimé
qu'il devait sortir de prison pour des
raisons de santé la Fédération
internationale de Scrabble par le déjà
de censure on est en Laponie en Finlande
et le Père Noël s'apprête à commencer sa
tournée il faut dire qu'il y a du monde
à gâté et que Noël se rapproche Charles
sauvage est libéré aujourd'hui pour
raison de santé il pourrait être expulsé
vers la France dans les 15 jours
[Musique]